hi I'm Allison Buchholz al and I'm a
program manager on the visual studio
platform team today we're going to take
a brief tour of what's new in Visual
Studio 2019 we're gonna look at our
enhanced art window the UI Refresh we've
made search improvements in the IDE
document health and one-click code
cleanup and finally debugger search and
stepping improvements let's go ahead and
dive in to our start window and our UI
refresh with the enhanced start window
you can quickly clone or check out code
from Azure DevOps github or elsewhere
you can get started on one of your
existing projects with open a project
solution or folder buttons which will
open the file explorer or you can pick
up with a recent project or folder you
can also create a new project and check
out our new project dialog experience
which allows you to search and filter
your project templates so you can
quickly get to what you're looking for
if you'd like to just open the IDE
without any code open go ahead and click
continue without code here at the bottom
now let's switch over to an instance of
Visual Studio that's already running
here you can see it looks quite
different from Visual Studio 2017 we
reduce clutter by minimizing the Chrome
and compressing the menu bar up here to
allow more space for what matters such
as your editor window you'll also notice
that the theme looks different as we've
updated our classic blue theme as you
just saw our enhanced art window allows
you to quickly check out a repo open an
existing project solution or folder or
get started with a brand new project
with our UI refresh we've added more
space for the things that matter
a modern UX and updated theming so that
you can quickly tell the difference
between visual studio 2017 and 2019 when
you have them installed side-by-side
let's dive in to the search improvements
in the IDE you'll notice I can hit this
search bar up here by clicking on it or
using ctrl Q as a shortcut as I type
you'll notice I get results almost
instantly and even though I've managed
to misspell something I'm still getting
relevant search results if we take a
closer look at any of these search
results you'll also notice that we have
the shortcuts here quickly so that you
don't have to look through your menu
commands in order to find those
shortcuts and finally if you're not
seeing what you're looking for you can
always quickly do an online search with
this button down here for a quick recap
you'll see that with our search you can
now activate it quickly with ctrl Q
we've got fuzzy search to help with any
misspellings as well as fast results you
can also look at shortcuts or search the
web if you don't find what you wanted
let's take a look now at document health
and code cleanup so down here in the
scroll bar you'll see that we have this
warning indicator this is our document
health this tells us if there are any
errors warnings or suggestions in our
current open document right now if I
hover over it it's letting me know I
have 29 warnings and 18 suggestions
which is why it's this yellow yield sign
if there were errors it would be a red
sign and if there are only suggestions
it'll be a blue this may change as we're
continuing to aerate on the design for
this feature if I right click you'll see
that I can actually navigate to the next
issue in the file or the previous I can
also do this with clicking on it or
shift click to go back now if I go ahead
and right click again you'll see that I
have the option to run code cleanup or
configure code clean up with configure
code cleanup I can actually look through
and understand which rules I'd like to
apply this is similar to format document
except that instead of just taking care
of your brace styling or margins or
spacing we can actually apply different
refactorings and code cleanup fixes
you'll see that I have the
apply implicit explicit type references
set here so I'll click OK now if I want
to run code cleanup and get rid of all
these warnings here and my error list I
can do that by hitting this command or
with the shortcut ctrl e ctrl C so if I
run code cleanup it will ask me to
verify which rules I'd like to run now
since I've already had apply implicit
explicit type preferences checked I'm
going to hit OK and you'll notice that
all of these change to var just as we'd
like them to and our error list is clean
and we've got a clean bill of health
from our document health indicator with
your document health indicator you'll be
able to understand whether there are
errors warnings or suggestions in your
open file you can also run and configure
code cleanup directly from this icon for
code cleanup you can configure which
rules to apply and the configure code
cleanup command and change the direction
of each rule in tools options text
editor code style finally let's look at
our debugger improvements first you can
expect step improvements by up to 50
percent depending on the size and
complexity of your project but hopefully
for those of you who spend a lot of time
stepping through you'll notice a
significant improvement in the
performance next let me draw your
attention to this window over here in
the otto's locals and watch window all
three of these now have a search bar
which allows you to search through the
items here instead of scrolling through
which is especially useful if you have
many many items in here so for example I
can search string just like that and
you'll notice that it takes me to the
first time string is encountered in this
case it happens to be a type but if
string were in value or name it would
also return social search results for
that I can go to my next instance here
or if I want to dig deeper and expand
any of these elements in search there I
can also search deeper right now our
default search depth is 3 so that means
it will open items three times and
expand three times inward before it ends
its search but you can change us to
whatever you'd like you can also limit
this search by searching only currently
expanded items so if you have many many
items or you're trying to scope the
search just to one particular object you
can set that we hope that you'll try out
all of these features and even more by
downloading the Visual Studio 2019
preview you can do this at akms slash vs
- preview if you want to know the full
range of things were introducing into
each preview release you can also check
out our release notes at AKMs /v s slash
preview - more - info and finally be
sure to check out all the other videos
here for connect at akms slash connect
2018